I do love cooking I do love baking you
know I bake bread all the time for my
family that's and you know I have
noticed cuz we've talked before food is
very important to you you're like you're
you believe food is important for being
happy yeah yes it's a celebration the
last chapter in my book is just eat the
bread right when they bring a basket out
to the table don't freak out don't say
oh no don't start crying just let them
put it down and if you want a bite
have a bite you deserve it what what are
you training for exactly that life is
hard
why shouldn't you be allowed to have one
bite of bread in your life very happy to
hear that
it's true though so you bake I do and
it's just a thing that you do all the
time I do it all the time
I started baking sourdough bread it
became a big thing online people are
sending me their recipes taking pictures
of their bread sending him it to them
sending it to me and asking for
suggestions and this whole thing and I
travel around the country when as a
stand-up I go visit bakeries and talk to
them and this sounds so absurd but I
literally now have a new show coming out
on Food Network in September called
baked where I travel around and visit
bakeries
you're gonna get you're gonna get some
people tuning in for the wrong reason I
think in my head who would be more happy
to see this show those guys a little old
lady yeah exactly they're both gonna
look great it's all coming together yeah
I mean I've tried so long to be on
television writing doing stuff and now I
just bake bread with my daughter and
that's why I'll have a show but I really
I really believe in it I truly truly
believe like we're all balled up and
going to these classes and trying to
starve ourselves and it's like we're
only here for a short while and the show
is based about on the people that make
this stuff they're such nice good you
don't need a bakery in the town you
don't need a bakery we need the
supermarket you need the power a bakery
is just a little place made by nice
people where you go and get a treat you
know what I mean it's very rare that an
a-hole decides I'm gonna bake cookies
for my community
Baker recently no they're all very sweet
people they're very nice so yeah I'm
excited about it and it's it's just
something that I truly believe in it's a
it's so funny to think you start out in
comedy and you're still doing comedy and
doing a great job at it but how it can
morph over time into well that's also
now bread yeah comedy and bread ya know
it's uh it's I work on a radio show I'm
writing books and I'm baking bread this
isn't exactly the Kevin Hart projectory
he started
you